and welcome to new video and I'll be
doing some blitz keep it sing again
because um I was just logging in on the
icy just to check if something's going
on before i go to bed but i am saw that
um there's quite an interesting match
going on here and it is some get to
Grand Master's playing here in three
minute blitz okay i prefer five but what
can you do okay we've got here on the
black side this is some Grandmaster from
a minion Robert off Shawn easy on or
something I write it in the description
he want to look it up but I can also
pick up the profile so you can you see
we can actually read it here he's the
world junior champion from two years ago
I think to fix something rated but the
more interesting play even as the white
player here you see a jump flag but this
is due to him being in Dortmund at the
moment because he played the super
tournament at the system most likely and
it's not one hundred percent sure but
most likely it's a sag ich I akhiyan
playing here his rumored to be this
raffaello guy and so let's see what
happens so we're right in the middle of
a game here and yeah white has picked up
a pawn on c6 and looks very good here
with the advanced queenside pawns but
black has got some counter play in the
center so let's see if he can convert
this nicely of course on the time is a
huge issue 3 minute chess always tricky
so I don't like my board here I readjust
it a little bit it was all a bit of a
hurry the setup here hope this is fine
yeah it looks ok so I think this is
better alright so let's see what happens
yeah white has got a nice advantage it's
true with the extra porn and he now push
this on with be five but I couldn't take
on d5 because of Quincy for now Rock d6
you've got Quincy seven but black might
be able to pick up b5 yeah he could take
me five okay yeah well black has also
some issues with the skin position it's
a bit down tricky to play it for black
with little time on the block moves like
h5m and Queenie fivesome some are
entering in the air entering in blacks
camp can be quite annoying to to face
yet just grab this but through t69 ok h7
was hanging okay so wyd still retains a
you 22 here with the blacks King running
around but it's not sure if it's a clear
win you gather down to 25 strings about
get white basically hoping for an error
on the black side with with so little
time at the open king how has he
blundered I fine but ok it's super
difficult so white is playing quickly
also are now got rid of the Queens and
as a winning routine game 22mm connected
past pants right is rather quick also
check check yeah this is quick but black
is not slow either putting up a huge
fight timewise here Wow yeah white
managed to grab the rookie let's see if
he can made in two seconds he might
mention me yeah for four tens of seconds
and at the end I hope they continue the
measure I just I just saw that he was
playing all right I hope for a rematch
here very very tough fight I hope is in
for some games really because the
quality to see such a good player and
playing blitz online yeah to better
Nakamura's not only he could be is in
Switzerland for the butte ornament but
most likely he's preparing for his first
round game and fortunately as
disconnected sorry I was hoping for for
more action here by Pocoyo keen but we
are yeah we got a glimpse 107 moves here
the spit in this game three minutes
alright some doesn't make sense to make
a five minute video so let's see what
else is on there we've got Conrad Hall
playing again darn walk is doesn't have
a title listed here but he is an
international master but would be a
grandmaster in about four weeks or
something when
when their titles again who ordered at
the Eastern bulan olympiad in Congress
okay it's playing in i am from from the
u.s. areas too let's check quickly if
there's an arm in the name of the mark
Ginsburg okay I don't know him so what's
what's happening here likes trying to
get some counter play the Sun oh it
wasn't a groom felt it looks a lot like
the room felt but yeah Black has got
some activity with the bishop on g7
bishop on f5 White has the better
structure though so I wants to exchange
some pieces and I could grab a sick song
like it's still quite active though
maybe g5 coming up all night h5 those
kind of moves so White's King has bidden
nerve in a tricky position here with the
legs pieces so being active in the
center I think now why should just take
the the night get rid of this piece and
the Bishop b5 is also on a threat really
quite a dangerous threat
okay it's taking some time yet it's a
it's a critical position what is
surprising or very complicated now
Knight takes f2 very tricky 9f 90 x f2
then Knight f6 Bishop takes Bishop takes
f6 and then you've got Queen h8 mate
coming up but black has got a ton of
checks tweenage one check King g3 994
yeah this would save like even now you
can take on f2 I think but um it's not
easy but not easy at all yeah but I
think you should take what about Bishop
b5 you should be five if I've didn't
look so bad either hmm
why didn't you play we should be five
not quite sure I have four of course f1
psyllium he can he could play a Ford
which would be five but this is working
i think so Knight f6 now Bishop f6
Bishop f6 Queen h1 checks 2394 check and
you get rid of them get rid of the the
bishop I think we see this line now
Bishop takes Queen tags that's some does
this have any point no this just
splittin blunders the Queen yeah he
needs to take with the bishop now now
Quinto h1 check an 94 to get em to get
rid of the bishop my black might even
continue attacking in a way King
anywhere where I can have three most
likely so black cannot give a check with
the Queen but you can take f6 now and
then try to get something on white six
post King something like night xf6 qui
takes and yeah maybe we should be six
first consolidating and then try to
invade them with the Queen giving some
checks yeah it's not a nice position to
play for white this King is really
exposed but if you as wide the managed
to get rid of the Queen's for instance
you have a nice end game with the a pond
so it's not so clear cut but what should
why do now can you play yeah if you play
move like a three black would play a
bishop d5 czechia in this Bishop t5
yeah yeah and I'll just just take it on
g2 this looks really really cool well
now black can just take me 20 it didn't
but black is still are still winning
Queen d5 check probably yeah black
missed a couple of clear wins now be
some nice win for black hair down locust
are really a strong opponent check
yeah man I did I don't see a 27 now this
looks like major this must be a maid
somehow Quinn to 2017 shade Quinn 26
check maybe we should be 79 turns over
check check Quinn be a check Quinn be a
check maybe game drawn yeah this is very
lucky for the white player Queen d6 just
wins here 26-game drawn like this this
is winning here you go here you have
shot this shop and win the Queen and and
this should should win also in a way
it's not so yeah but you can take in and
just just push push the pawn here
alright so our next game here let's see
who is who's who else is playing here
let's jump right in this is I is yakov
Nora which is an American play a very
good plus player against Grandmaster
blue be maxing blue be also Blitzer
specialist and down we've got what mods
material equality and it adjust the
board slightly here this material
equality and blacks King looks a little
bit shaky here yeah with the year d
successor is a nice threat also what's
all night f5 coming maybe the a black
looks a critical here
yeah maybe he just needs to ya know not
have five may be right at five job like
black and black has a Quincy five maybe
who in strife or couldn't be six yeah
getting rid of the Queen but why this
better Lucy one and you basically have
any sort of extra pawn on d5 and to
quite a strong one so why just can
centralize his forces try to win with
this extra porn I mean it's not an extra
porn mathematically but in effect the
dew point is extra because double B porn
doesn't do much so no white enters into
blacks position he also has this monster
not only six and the rukon c8 which
really limits black so Sam quite quite
nice for white it's not super clear cut
kini 496 would be huge embarrassing yeah
very nice very nicely played controlling
at five so that the night cannot enter
so white tries to to limit blacks play
and to always stay active oh this this
wasn't the best I guess like someone
escape but he's down to 12 seconds so
very difficult to to to hold this
so yeah black will lose on time now he's
got a better end game but ok so it's
three minutes yes God loogie offering a
draw I don't think yakiv will take it we
just winded sometime very very rare that
you see people exempting drawers and
those discounted positions in three
minute games of the four fits on time
yeah time one so let's jump to do down
rock again I think I'll i go to follow
him think it's always interesting it's
got very nice rounded style ok he was
very lucky in this earlier game against
areas too but usually he very nicely
controls the position alright so I'm
it's playing a Spanish player here and
we have some some line here of the
London system where black quickly and
got some initiative on the queenside
just go quickly through this and yeah
black is somewhat better here because of
this activity he just needs to yeah when
one of those pawns he and you will
likely promote B or C porn so why does
somewhat tied up here but ok this
transformation I'm not so sure about
this is so great it's not so easy to see
how I'm like should improve its position
because what controls the the e-file so
you cannot enter with the rook the end
rook a eight well something doesn't
really bring bring much positive so not
sure why does some pretty solid now you
need to be careful about the pawns this
bishop on f6 is somewhat somewhat dump
piece it cannot
attack anything here and it's also a
very bad defender of the pawns see form
can be a easy prey for white maybe yeah
something like we need to 92like and
play rook c8 but it's not not great ok
so maybe white oh this is if this looks
weird opening up the position here yeah
okay the king is still safe on g3 but I
mean I wouldn't have done it I think
more I would be more inclined to use the
deep on and keep the King save but okay
maybe it was ok but well not the kind of
player I would have chosen what is why
try maybe he tries to exchange Queens
yeah this would also be nice then try to
win the sea for porn so Queenie 8 is
this a good move I had not so clear if
you exchange then King g7 black also
threatens g5 using yeah but now rookie
to and g5 and I don't know like black is
back in business I guess we take on f1
or you cannot recapture with the King
because we have six winning a piece yeah
I think the worst is over for like he
can also just take a for King f3 and
then chop off this this night and it's
not yeah it tries to win somehow maybe
rook c1 c2 something like this very
risky the other way of playing would
have been just the draw check
yeah I think black is trying to play for
loss here in a way yeah it happens you
you have a nice position and just ya
phir you you should win somehow and then
you you just try too hard it happens to
me really a lot so I sympathize with
this yeah now just King e5 king d 5c for
like and we'll the vporn of this is
weird why not King me five give me five
Roxy to rupee 1 Kings if on you you will
pick up the beep on and white will have
connected passed pawns now you can stop
liking me five why doesn't he do this
Roxy to rookie one rugby to King c4 and
black cannot move his rook without
losing the beep on then you just push
the deep on this is just a win King me
five I mean it so it's also close to the
only move what what else should you play
here I take some time let's see if he
finds it cleanly five just wins i'm not
sure if there's some other good move I
mean what else would you play if you
give a check on left to black players
King e6 and this happy to have her skin
position improved yeah now is he found
it why not to e 1 u 1 would have been
better because then black doesn't have
rugby one the rock own belongs back on
the I'm there on the first rank alright
the endgame lots of weird things
possibly happening ok so now black can
at least get the Jeep on and get into
some sort of race king rope kelly brook
g one or rogue t1 check and then Ruby g1
grabbing the short form
check yeah white is still ok but you
really am yeah gave like far too much
here in this position should have had a
similar structure with another ton of
extra Tempe and now now I'm willing to
bet on black already I no no the
tendency of this game it's just just bad
for wide no tendency the trench and
let's say the trend is a better word I
had white should induce it's got his
King near the pawns and it's also better
time wise so just can you five maybe
okay
look G for rookie for him India to
retreat to III yeah like us winning now
yeah wyd really blundered this end game
away it was winning at the at the
beginning yeah shame but well yeah black
and just push the Jeep on now he should
have taken a bit more time before
playing walk c5 he this pawn just
promotes an ex-king as some in front of
the porn so the connected passed pawns
him so he don't have white give me six
and that's it and keys he finally pawns
are stopped now and you can just pick
them up now quite resigned yeah y term
sport AU chur CH an CE in this game to
to get a big scub yeah his player holds
place a bit shaky this evening I guess
could have lost earlier and drew and
well this was was a loss also but in
very instructive endgame okay I was
trying to to look at it quickly but we
have got the next game going yeah
against them another grand master he
grandma's asleep are slip back I don't
know from Argentina Argentina and got a
rare variation of the Queens gambit and
which is posed in to sort of exchange
variation well Black has played the same
somewhat superfluous move a 6-bit it gap
it's not not so great um
for black but I need to adjust a
structure here black has managed to earn
two exchanges his bishop which often
helps him structurally this e 70 d6
Bishop is the good bishop but very often
in these kind of structures you simply
have too much too many pieces and you
need to need to exchange some of them
you have less room than space so I'm
exchanging of pieces is some very often
known your helpful alright we transpose
into some isolated pawn structure here
with white having played the move f3 and
usually black as some it's okay if Y
tends them played this f3 move like as
the count to play against this pawn but
you shouldn't exchange so many pieces
maybe maybe 95 as an idea than some
point all right so white ones too i
exchanged a couple of pieces now and
then baby three been MIA yeah this is
some I think now really a slightly
better for white there's too much
exchanged here so that like doesn't have
any concrete play against III end well
black still has the isolated pawn lots
of end games will be a worse film
yeah but not not much happening here
really black seems fairly active 93 may
be coming up how do you protect you
three even a 2 also hanging mmm i'm not
sure what why should do here to protect
his stuff 93 maybe 93 and that pig RB
393 roxy three rookie three should be
playable it's a somewhat strange pin but
you've got the rookie won this threat
yeah i can just take now just take you
three rookie one checkmate is threatened
if y place night see to you can play
repeat you encounter tactus the snide so
now just rookie one and rook somewhere
up d 1 yeah that needs to get out of
this the spin on the third rank so
rookie one now yeah Black has a pretty
clear extra porn i would say okay guess
the loop on but roxy seven now coming up
I think rookie one was stronger before
you also this also threatened them 91
check so I think this about the better
move
yeah it's still not so easy I was
thinking a bit how black should bow yeah
well exchanging roxas is absolutely a
check yeah we're now now why this fine
again because p7 you cannot you cannot
keep this heaven here yeah now black
must be very cautious this can easily be
worse for him with the whites night
whites nights being active why it's
nights wow this is difficult to
pronounce for me um yeah no 95 had
you've got the deep on blocked and
whites King is all so quick and joining
this is very critical for black now the
dip on can can get lost easily
mmm what now maybe black was just in
time to to keep this position together
check
hey
ya know black might be even even better
he check how this was an entrance for
school t3 now are very nice flavor black
may be possible that that is able to to
push us a pawn home now King before and
then use the Knights to to get rid of
whites night so that you can maybe a
promoted upon night well night night
night Katie now you can just use the
King I think King um BTW 3c to something
like this oh wow we are still tricky
yeah I tries to stop the a porn with the
knives but what has also got the each
pawn whoohoo race now but they are black
should be should be quicker really give
just from mode and the beep onus is also
fast I think black should be winning
hmm so I'm 93 checking DS King up you
also could have done back and now just
push the B porn ah ok so now Queen
exchange is this winning or I guess it
isn't your mouth changing queens now I
think doesn't win check this must be is
this a draw ok so black wants to secure
the draw with nothing on the clock maybe
it could have still 1 i'm not quite sure
it was too quick for me to do
congratulate this ok maybe made the the
decent dumb practical choice with them
with them so little time yeah game with
ups and downs in the end game I think at
one point wide was very very good i
think this this kind of position must be
very good for white but somehow it
didn't materialize scientist f5 most
move what's really strong I'm sorry
check yeah just this must be winning
takes hmm head still druggie it's so
tricky amazing 94 not much alternatives
very tricky endgame alright so let's um
watch the next game the last game for
the session I really need to go to bed
at some point but I didn't plan to do
this really so on we've got a Kings
Indian attack here and not quite sure
what white is doing yeah blacky's
gaining space I think a black should be
already very good him only white play
would be a yeah with them with the f
porn but black has got ya all his pieces
forget towards um yeah hindering wide
from from playing a form ok now I can
just grab this porn
see a black should be should be very
good here with that some at Wantage on
the queenside and whites queen is
somewhat astray on a six but now you
cannot catch it i guess i'm not sure
what's he form i want more thinking
thinking about 90 to see for something
like this using the square for peace
what this now all is human after all
people just blundered this bishop or is
there some Queen trap and when the Queen
doesn't have much much space maybe
Bishop h3 now and cannot exchange on c6
Roxy 6 really catches the Queen well
this is tricky Roxy six okay I may be
queen of eight and eight eggs before
then why does got two pieces form two
pieces for rook basically what why
didn't you take on f8 yeah now Black is
just winning a very weird play this was
I mean if you recognize that you lose
the Queen why not take the rook instead
of a minor piece okay so black should
just win now with this extra material
there's just not much else going on okay
what might try to play Knight to f5 or
something your drumming up something on
the edge farm but ok Black has just got
extra material
hard for me to believe that this
shouldn't be a clear win maybe rugby
seven iya rugby 7 h-7 get rid of one
rook this would help
what can take on g5 now he could have
taken on g5 this would would have been
quite good I think hmm mad still it's
still a bit tricky yeah rook rook edge
city's water would be yeah you can you
can give the Queen back and should have
a very good end game now like a
threatening night be three winning the
bishop or in this case night c 1 2 D 3
winning yeah well all pawns d3b to
basically all pawns are lost now I think
white could've taking on g5 a couple of
moves ago this would have been maybe
tricky still he had this one's a bishop
nice nice little shot white resign kinky
2nite c4 check and picking up the bishop
yeah quite a quite a strange game weapon
I meaning especially this move why would
you take here and not take on f8 and get
get the night I think white is still
better than so very tricky and a blitz
game but I know looks quite obvious and
yeah here Bishop g5 on 95 and then you
can just check here you cannot go to the
FR because of rook air-five picking up
the Queen I think this is a draw it's
only enough cool yeah I think what could
have drawn he was taking or I don't know
it's hard for black to avoid the draw I
guess what's pieces what would be all
over the place here if you take on g5 i
can now maybe I can can
you mean I can oops No
oh no I bet i butchered this up Ian I
wanted to look at look at the game but
it didn't work out no I started a game
with myself not really a what I wanted
all right but I managed to catch 40
minutes of ya Grandmaster blitz here and
fortunately and not more with with the
kayaking at the beginning would have
been nice but some other interesting
games I think as well yeah thanks for
watching I hope to do those again in the
future just a matter of luck when you're
online and on kept some some interesting
player that you that you can follow all
right let's talk soon